one of the things you can do an image
posting package is resizing images or
rotating images and so on and when you
do this in any program paint on there
Photoshop the and so on you have an
option to choose how you want it to
scale the pixels so do you want it to be
nearest neighbor or by linear or by
cubic so today we're going to cover
image transformations but mostly
rescaling because it's a simple one and
we'll look a bit at nearest neighbor and
bilinear and so on let's imagine we've
got a three by three image so there's a
three by three image it's you know high
quality and I want to scale this image
by a factor of let's say three okay
which is going to mean a nine by nine
image so cut to a long shot of me going
like this frantically so this isn't
going to be nine by nine because I've
gone that I've gone to were not
important it's not important I don't
know how many this is I'm counted it
doesn't matter right I'm scaling this
and it extends this way for some
indefinite amount of time depending on
what my scaling factor is okay let's
leave it at that
now if I wanted to scale this the
obvious way to do it is just to multiply
these values by some pixel coordinate
amount so let's say X becomes 3x and put
them in this image and then problem
solved right so that would be might you
first get how it work let's say it has
120 this is 121 this is you know
grayscale let's say 115 and so on we say
right well this one stays in this corner
because this is naught naught naught
times a scaling factor of 3 is also
naught so we say this is going to be 120
okay that's my first guess at this 121
is at 1 0 so it becomes 3 0 so naught 1
2 3 and it becomes 121 if this is 100
then 100 goes down here and this is 110
and that goes over here and these are
all 0 right which is about the worst
scaling ever this isn't going to work
like this approach it would just look
like a black image if you zoomed really
far out you might see some colors in it
but really the majority of this image is
black and completely useless so this
isn't I have scaled this image but not
properly right because the problem is
that there is no pixel in this image
that maps of this one right this maps
are somewhere between 2 pixels so that's
the problem we need to solve all right
and that's the problem being solved by
nearest neighbor or by linear or by
cubic so
natural fat when we want to scale an
image we do this process in Reverse we
create the bigger image and then for
each pixel we look back and see where
are we supposed to be getting our sample
from it is between two pixels we have to
think about what we do if it's on and
pick a little great we'll just take that
pixel value so I'm up my instinct here
would be that your 1/20 would would be x
3 so all those 9 would be 120 yes that's
pretty close to newest neighbor so what
we do here we say well but this is a
value of 1 0 which is going to be a
third zoom it when we scale back so
we're closer to 120 than we are to 121
so this becomes 120 right this one goes
down to 2/3 down here so it's closer to
121 then it's to 120 so we say that's
121 this probably gets 121 and so on
this is why when you make your image
bigger using nearest neighbor it
continues to look pixelated because
that's exactly what it's doing it's
preserving all that information by just
duplicating a bunch of pixels in these
gaps right now that doesn't seem like a
very good way of doing it but of course
that might be what you want to do if
you're a pixel artist who's doing you
know pixel art then scaling it and
having it all blur will be edges it's
completely useless for you so depending
on what your situation is you might want
to do that the other thing is that
strictly speaking then we haven't in
essence made up any data this pixel
value is still one of the pixel values
that was in this original image because
you could argue we don't know for sure
what's going on between these two pixels
it could be anything it's just that the
camera isn't high enough resolution to
capture it with bilinear interpolation
what we're assuming is but the thing
that's going on between here is entirely
obvious it's just a line between the two
okay so we're going to take an average
let's have a look at some of these so
we've got a value of 120 and we've got a
value of 121 all right and this is a
pixel zero and this is a pixel one and
we're going to be filling in these two
gaps here so this one here is going to
be a value of 1/3 or not 0.3 recurring
and this one's going to be at a value of
2/3 already people can probably see
what's going to happen here for this one
we're going to take 2/3 of this in a
furnace and vice versa
okay so the formula is actually
essentially a weighted sum of these two
things
but the weighting depends on how far
along this distance between them you are
okay so this is what linear
interpolation
does so in this case we would say 120 to
121 isn't a very helpful example because
we're going to have to do some rounding
at some point and then kind of defeat
the whole object of what we're doing so
let's let's pick it more obvious one
okay so let's say that this pixel value
is a hundred and this pixel value is two
hundred and we are trying to sample the
pixel position a third of the way along
this is very straightforward so all we
have to do is we have to do 2/3 times by
100 plus 1/3 times by 200 all right and
if we sum them up what do we get this is
66 ish okay this is also coincident lis
66 ish and so we add them up and we get
about 132 or something like that
well we've got a hundred thirty-three
the coding don't we we get a value
exactly 1/3 of the way along from the
scale of 100 to 200 okay so that's
linear interpolation so the only the
only thing we have to worry about now is
how do we extend this to two dimensions
and again not very it's not very
challenging so if I just take away this
piece of paper instead of having two
endpoints we now have four okay so we
have one here we have one here we have
one here and we have one here now this
is x1 y1 and this is x2 y1 and this is
x1 y2 and x2 y2 and we're trying to find
some position here X Y and more often
but not if you're scaling in image or
doing a rotation or something along
these lines you're going to find
yourself sitting somewhere in between
two pixels what we do is we first
interpolate these intermediate values
here okay so we do what we just did
along between this line so we find this
is just about 40% is it so we we do the
formula that says what's the value 40%
along from here to here okay and we get
some value here and then we do the same
here so what's 40% along here we do some
value here and then we interpolate
between these two values to get this
final value output and that's how we can
map between four values to some
arbitrary position in amongst them and
that's basically what happens when you
click bilinear when you want to resample
you image so any kind of scaling any
kind of rotation anything that is going
to involve a scale it doesn't fit
exactly on the pixels from the original
image and remember we're doing this in
Reverse so we go from our new image back
we look back into our original image and
find out where we need to get the color
form so back to our original example
this x1 y1 is going to be 120 and x2 y1
is going to be 121 and these two are
going to be 100 110 and we can have any
position in between these pixels
depending on what we're doing tor image
we're making it a factor of 10 larger
then is going to be 10 increments
between these things if we're making it
smaller there might be fewer than 1 you
know it might it you know does that work
as well yeah so if you'll make it so
actually the scaling you're doing makes
no difference right if the scaling is
smaller than 1 then you're still going
to have pixel values that sit in between
the original pixels it's just not going
to be very many of them anymore because
you're actually making the image smaller
and the same with a rotation all that
changes is the transform we used to get
from these positions in our destination
image to these positions in our source
image the only other thing to remember
about linear interpolation is that it is
just that linear if we looked at a row
of pixels sidon then you might get a
value if this is 0 you might get a value
here and here and here and here and here
and here like this right so this could
be our image different intensity levels
right so just for a grayscale image we
might have something that looks a bit
like this if we look sidon now if we
were just scaling 1 to 1 we're going to
be getting this value and getting this
value and that's fine if we're scaling
somewhere refer it away along or 2/3 of
way between this one and this one we're
going to need to interpolate these
values which corresponds to finding
positions along these lines here and
this is what linear interpolation is
doing it's fitting straight lines
between these objects and finding the
positions along it that looks like a
very pointed feature that you've just
done with those lines so is it I'm
guessing that we can start drawing
curves right that's right so the problem
with by linear interpolation and it's
not much of a problem if you're just
let's say we stomping by a factor of 2
or something so vit you know you're only
creating one intermediate value it comes
down to what our assumptions are about
what's happening in the image between
these points it might be more reasonable
to say well maybe given this underlying
data member these two are part of it it
might be something a lot more like that
you know a bit smoother so that if we
sample here it's closer to
this one but it is to this one and so on
okay that's what bicubic interpolation
does but that's what if in video
that's 66 ish okay this is 66 again
rights we've done what we get 120 okay
so 420 something recurring yeah let's
start that again
so we go so this is 60 60 okay this is
also
[Music]